So, hey it's me, Destin.
Welcome to Smarter Every Day.
I do a YouTube show.
- Okay, well, that's so cool.
(Destin) Yeah.
- She's like, "what do I have to..."
- Hello!
[Destin laughs]
(Destin) We're here with
Johan's roomate and friend.
- Yeah.
- And we're going to...
I don't condone smoking, ever.
However, Johan's roomate smokes,
and we're going to light her
cigarette with a high powered laser.
Because we... because we can, really.
Goggle up.
- The professional's here, so...
(Destin) Are you ready?
Everyone have goggles?
- Yeah.
(Destin) Okay, you come to this side.
Okay. Yep, hold on, are you powering up?
Hold on, let me step over the beam.
- [Speaks Dutch]
(Destin) Okay.
(Johan) [Unintelligible]
(Destin) Yeah.
(Johan) ...High power.
(Johan) [Speaks Dutch]
- Oh.
- Oh, nice!
(Destin) Yeah.
[Conversation in Dutch]
(Destin) Yeah, there you go.
- [Speaks Dutch]
(Destin) There you go.
(Johan) [Speaks Dutch]
(Destin) Smoking is wrong.
[Everybody laughs]
(Destin) Did it work?
- Yeah, nice!
[Destin and girl laugh]
(Johan) [Mutters in Dutch]
(Destin) Alright.
There you have it. That's how a physicist
and an engineer light cigarettes
that they don't smoke, in the Netherlands.
[Girl laughs]
Thumbs up, Johan.
[Destin laughs]
Let's see.
(Johan) This is where it gets silly.
If I rotate the block...
(Destin) Yeah, hold on.
It's hard to adjust the focus ring at
the same time. Hold the goggles please.
There we go.
Holland or the Netherlands?
- You can actually use both.
- Really?
- Yeah. I usually say the Netherlands.
It's, uh... it's like, more
professional than "we're in Holland!"
[Destin laughs]
[Music]
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.